Au palace à Paris à partir du 15 octobre
"chanson entrainante des Beach boys"
"explosion"
Ce que tu ressens quand tu trouves 5 euros par terre
(ok !)
"musique"
J'vais prendre des croissants..... s'il vous plaît
Tout le monde rêve de faire ça en réunion
Alors ce trimestre, les chiffres sont en chute totalle, va falloir réagir !
Excusez-moi, j'men bat les c***lles
"claquement de doigts"
Captain America
Je suis Captain America.... avec un énorme bouclier
enfin énorme... c'est un frisbee en fait, attrape !
Comportement d’ascenseur
Ah ! Attendez !!
Ahhh ! Yes ! Yes
Bonsoir !
Les chat qui sortent leurs  griffes
Ça me soule a chaque fois qu'un chat se barre de mes genoux, il se barre en sortant ses griffes
C'est comme si moi je faisait
Aller ciao ! (claque)
Heu excuse me, it's my room!
Au ju-jitsu j'ai appris pas mal de prise    ouais
Donc la en fait faut disloqué le coude du gars
Et là, faut péter toute l’articulation
*crie de joie excité des abonné(e)s*
Ce soir ? Non, je peut pas. Je pense que mon mec m'a prévu une soirée romantique
Tire putain tire putain ! casse toi !
Ok Claudette, on se fait une petite photo ?
Ok les gars, on se fait un petit selfie oklm
*rire*
Allez une photo
putain je suis trop sombre on me voit pas là !
bah, fallait pas être noir !
Michel raciste
tu lis quoi ?
de la philo
le rire des gens
ya des gens quand ils rient, on dirait qu'il veulent s'inventer un style
crrr crrr
éééééééhh on éééééh on
eh on  eh on
qui suis-je ?
vous êtes l'homme qui pèse un max, n'est-ce pas ?
exact !
attend, on part que deux jours hein.
tu veux vraiment prendre toutes ces affaires ?
tain mais ça va j'ai pris le strict minimum là !
Aller ! t'est un homme ou pas ?
"musique de thug life"
"bébé qui pleure"
Allo ?
Ouai j'tappelle vite fait mais j'ai pas le temps j'suis hyper occupé, euh... on s'rappelle plus tard ?
SALUT JORDAN !!
Jordan :ooooh vache
Jordan : OH LA VACHE !!
Jordan : oh la vache !!
Norman : Tien cadeau des place de spectacle pour mon spectacle
Jordan : Oh merci beaucoup
Norman : il est mignon le Jordan
Tu va pas pleurer hein ? :)
Jordan : oh la vache j'arrive pas a y croire..
Norman : aller jordan ♪♫ allez jordan♪♫ aller jordan♪♫
Jordan : j'etais en train de regardé tes video la
Norman : tu dechire fait moi un check
toi et moi on est pote hein ! on est Bro
Attend cette homme a dix ans et porte deja du louis vuitton
Il est vraiment deja ..... au top de la mode
♪♫Venez me voir en spectacle a paris , au palace , a partir du 15 octobre ♪♫
Voila... C'est un prochain tube